Tom Sizemore was born and raised in
Detroit Michigan in 1961 while his home
life seemed stable his youth was clouded
by misbehavior and criminal activity
Sizemore chose a path of higher
education as his Escape briefly
attending Michigan State University for
a year before switching to Wayne State
University it was there that he
developed an interest in the Performing
Arts while his early days on the NYC
acting scene weren't easy Sizemore
ascended relatively quickly into a
steady stream of credits on the big and
small screens seismore's Big Break came
with a small but notable role in Oliver
Stone's 1989 anti-war film born on the
4th of July he played a wheelchair-bound
Vietnam vet alongside the film star Tom
Cruise helping tell the true life story
of Ron Kovac a former Soldier turned
anti-war activist born finished in the
top 20 highest grossing films of the
year and was nominated for multiple
Oscars suddenly Sizemore was on his way
to becoming a recognizable face to
audiences and he had begun laying the
groundwork for the gruff tough tortured
characters which would soon become his
trademark
Sizemore became an in-demand choice for
several of Hollywood's most acclaimed
filmmakers establishing himself as an
actor who could portray a very specific
type of character according to his
biography on Turner Classic Movies he
built a reputation for creating a quote
intense fast talking Persona you think I
like this hair man ah you think I like
these clothes it's no surprise then that
some of the biggest directors at the
time were all eager to put him on screen
following in the wake of born on the 4th
of July Sizemore appeared in films like
the Mickey Rourke vehicle
Harley-Davidson and the Marlborough man
Wesley Snipes passenger 57 and the Bruce
Willis flick Striking Distance by the
early 90s he was Landing featured roles
in films like the Robert Downey Jr
starring Heart and souls Sizemore earned
a Saturn award nomination for best
supporting actor for that film and went
on to endear himself to the emerging
Quentin Tarantino crowd with standout
work in the director's early Scripps
Natural Born Killers and True Romance
the crown jewel of this era for Sizemore
however was his performance as a career
Bank Robert and Michael Mann's 1995
crime classic heat working alongside
Legends like Robert De Niro Val Kilmer
and Al Pacino Sizemore very much held
his own minting an unforgettable
character
as quickly as sizemore's star seemed to
emerge so too did his drug addiction in
2010 on an episode of Celebrity Rehab
with Dr Drew Sizemore explained that he
had been using and ordealing since he
was 15 years old as tends to happen with
Fame and success his Hollywood career
had only exacerbated the issue Sizemore
later told Larry King in a 2010 CNN
interview that he had been addicted to
cocaine meth and heroin and separately
admitted that he was so high in 2010 he
didn't even know his rehab appearance
was being filmed
the addiction had become I didn't even
like it anymore but I could not stop
doing it things got particularly bad
around the time of 1995's heat and
that's when friends and co-stars began
trying to get him help seismar recounted
in his 2013 Memoir by some miracle I
made it out of there that he had an
intervention that included Robert De
Niro he wrote I sit down and Bob came in
and goes okay okay now we can talk now
you listen to me I'm no psychiatrist but
you're either going to go to rehab or go
to prison and in walks a cop but
sizemore's difficulties continued by the
time of 2003's Stephen King adopted
dreamcatcher the last major Studio film
of his career Sizemore was claiming to
have stayed sober for the shoot but
interviews for the film became
problematic questions from reporters
about the movie were met with poetry
recitations and incoherence as
sizemore's difficulties continued Heart
and souls and Natural Born Killers
co-star Robert Downey Jr became a
trusted friend particularly since he had
successfully overcome similar demons
Sizemore recall in 2011 Robert told me
this was inevitable you really want your
career back then you get it back and
you're like whoa you think you might get
[__] up again because you have access
to things again and you worry you may
disappear at the time Sizemore claimed
to be two years sober himself thanks in
part to a live-in sobriety companion
hired at the urging of Downey
hey Buckaroo
yeah it really came through for me back
there that meant a lot to me at the
height of sizemore's career he became
involved with other celebrities some
famous and others Infamous Sizemore
dated Edie Falco before moving to Los
Angeles in 1991. he wrote In by some
miracle I made it out of there that on
the set of Passenger 57 he began a fling
with co-star Elizabeth Hurley that
concluded when she returned to longtime
Beau Hugh Grant Sizemore further claims
to have had an affair with Juliette
Lewis on the set of Natural Born Killers
when he was 32 and she was 19. his most
high profile romance however was
undoubtedly with so-called Hollywood
Madam Heidi fleis who was convicted of
running a prostitution ring in 1994.
after three years in prison she began a
headline grabbing relationship with
Sizemore but by 2003 their story had
become one of harassment and physical
abuse Sizemore was convicted on multiple
counts serving seven months in jail and
a subsequent four months in drug
treatment after repeated fail drug tests
while on probation prior to fleis
Sizemore had been married to The Bold
and the Beautiful actress Maeve Quinlan
from 1996 to 1999. sizemore's drug
problems and violent temperament
allegedly played a significant role in
their eventual split Quinlan said in
2019 I am finally ready to say this and
make it public that I am a survivor of
domestic abuse that's something I intend
to bring awareness to in my 50s
the most notable role in sizemore's
career would come in 1998 with the actor
playing jaded battle weary technical
Sergeant Mike Horvath and Steven
Spielberg's award-winning Blockbuster
Saving Private Ryan a loyal to the end
Soldier under Tom Hanks Captain John
Miller Sizemore stood his ground
alongside the likes of up-and-comers Vin
Diesel Matt Damon and Giovanni Ribisi
the result was an instant classic of a
film telling a tragic story of War lost
brotherhood and sacrifice for a group of
soldiers sent on a Rescue Mission in the
thick of World War II Spielberg was
meticulous in his casting for Ryan and
had become convinced that Sizemore was
ideal for capturing the older rugged
style of 1940s veterans
Gear Up
Spielberg explained in 1998 the people
in World War II actually looked
different than people look today a lot
of the people I cast in this picture I
was looking at their faces to match the
faces I saw on the newsreels with a face
for the battlefield Sizemore had been
originally slated to appear in another
high-profile War film at the time
Terence Malik's The Thin Red Line but
when he got the call from Spielberg he
Departed the star-studded cast for
Saving Private Ryan
while sizemore's struggles with
substance abuse were hardly a secret
they eventually became a fundamental
part of his public Persona to the point
where his once formidable acting prowess
felt like a fading memory scandal after
Scandal made the actor hard for
audiences to accept without some sort of
openness about his pitfalls one Scandal
and a long series of them was his leaked
sex tape in 2005 released by Vivid
Entertainment while Sizemore was no
stranger to tabloids by the mid-2000s
this was an entirely different kind of
Scandal for the once prestigious actor
Sizemore also appeared in a documentary
series about his road to sobriety in
2007 VH1 released the six episode
reality doc series entitled shooting
Sizemore which chronicled the trials and
tribulations of the actors fight through
substance abuse the series was marketed
as a sort of cathartic project for Tom
Sizemore to deal with his personal
demons while redeeming himself in the
eyes of the public ultimately however
the series did little to help as
recently as 2019 and 2020 seismar was
still being arrested for drug possession
it it was hard to find a more eagerly
anticipated or star-studded TV series in
2017 then Twin Peaks the return a
long-awaited third season from David
Lynch and Mark Frost of what is often
considered one of the greatest series of
all time when it began airing on
Showtime viewers were bombarded with one
surprise after another including the
gritty greasy charm of Sizemore
unexperienced by most pop culture Savvy
viewers in nearly a decade and a half
and what a performance it needed to be
Sizemore played a key part in the Dougie
Jones storyline which had series star
Kyle McLaughlin portraying a naive
dim-witted tulpa of FBI agent Dale
Cooper the character walked and
occasionally spoke but was essentially a
blank slate requiring scene Partners
like Sizemore James Belushi and Naomi
Watts to do most of the heavy lifting at
least Exposition wise what were you and
Bushnell discussing earlier so you
walking to his office carrying a bunch
of files
Sizemore did an admirable job and when
coupled with smaller roles around the
same time on It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia Hawaii Five-O and Lucifer
as well as six episodes of the series
shooter it seemed like he could be on
the cusp of a Mickey Rourke type
re-emergence but it wasn't to be
although prior seismo controversies may
have included drugs physical abuse and
other offenses things took an even more
disturbing turn in late 2017 The
Hollywood Reporter published a piece
detailing the actor's repellent behavior
during the 2003 filming of a crime drama
released as Born Killers it was reported
that Sizemore had been forced to leave
the utah-based film set after being
accused of sexually molesting an 11 year
old actress working on the production he
later ended up returning for reshoots on
the film and the story never leaked to
the Press until 14 years later Sizemore
categorically denied the charges he said
in a statement posted to his Twitter
account then later deleted I have done
many things I deeply regret however I
did not do this the victim in question
did eventually press charges against
Sizemore in 2020. ultimately a
utah-based judge dismissed the case
without any details on the legal
reasoning for doing so according to USA
Today after a lifetime of acting highs
and personal lows Sizemore began 2023
with a physical trauma from which he
would never recover around 2 am on
February 18 2023 the actor suffered a
brain aneurysm at his home he was moved
to a local Los Angeles hospital and
listed in critical condition the
aneurysm came less than a month after
Sizemore appeared in Beverly Hills at
the premiere of Bermuda Island a
deserted island horror movie released in
January of 2023. sizemore's manager and
spokesperson Charles Lago described the
actor on February 19th as being in a
wait and see situation at the time
things were not looking hopeful on the
28th Salem News broke that sizemore's
doctors were guiding the actor's family
through an end-of-life decision Lago
told the LA Times doctors informed his
family that there is no further hope and
have recommended end-of-life decision
Sizemore was taken off life support and
on March 3rd pronounced dead Lago told
TMZ it is with great Sadness and Sorrow
I have to announce that actor Thomas
Edward Sizemore aged 61 passed away
peacefully in his sleep today at St
Joseph's Hospital Burbank his brother
Paul and twin boys Jaden and Jagger were
at his side if you or anyone you know
has been a victim of sexual assault help
is available visit the rape abuse and
incest National Network website or
contact Reigns National helpline at
1-800-656-hope 4673
[Music]
foreign